but the other favorite gift that I got
was the insanity that was Donald Trump
on yesterday he is the gift that keeps
on giving but in actuality this story is
about a press release from the orange
see that some people think compared
Donald Trump to Jesus let's take a look
at it all right so here it is merry
Christmas to all this is from rinse
prank spirits from the RNC he says over
two millennia ago a new hope was born it
sounds like the opening to Star Wars a
savior who would offer the promise of
salvation to all mankind blah blah blah
just say just as three wise men did on
that night this Christmas heralds a time
to celebrate the good news of a new king
you can clip there that's that's good
let's let's talk about that so a lot of
people took this to mean that Reince
Priebus was comparing Donald Trump to
Jesus are comparing calling Donald Trump
the new king this is to me I think this
is more about how confusing the English
language could actually be I don't think
that he was actually comparing Donald
Trump to Jesus or stating that Donald
Trump was a the new king however I can
see if people read that sentence and
have no context to religious jargon I
can see how they can mistake that what
do you think yeah I think there was some
folks on the Left who are kind of
overreacting to to seeing that but I
mean Jesus has been referred to as the
new king for with centuries now and
maybe they just didn't understand that
context yeah and I guess it speaks to
the godless liberals that we are right
yeah well godless oh of course we're not
going to understand if you say a new
King we're think you're talking about
the newly elected president so it's
really a story about the English
language and lack of context and it's
it's it to me could have been a funny
story except for Sean Spicer who is
Donald Trump's incoming press secretary
you could see a picture of him on the
screen instead of doing what a press
secretary does which is to clarify to
make things complain and explain instead
of doing that he decided to do this on
Twitter um he said it said that BuzzFeed
been a right
for BuzzFeed obviously condones this
attack on Christ oh such a holy day for
Christians buzz fees must apologize so
here's the spin and this is amazing
right so because the left the godless
liberal left they don't understand the
context of a new king and they wrote a
story about it if you go to BuzzFeed you
can see the story is basically saying
some people are confused by this
statement okay fine but because but fees
BuzzFeed wrote that story Sean Spicer
instead of clarifying or instead of
taking the the sarcastic high road and
saying you guys are idiots because
basically the left they were idiots with
this one right this is a non-story but
instead of taking that road route he
decides that this is an attack on Christ
these are the the war on Christmas right
that's exactly it i think it's just that
the latest chapter to the war on
christmas cuz they feel like they've won
that war now that Donald Trump's been
elected president and of course they're
gonna double down whenever they can
right because you know you could not
possibly say Merry Christmas while Obama
was president even though he said Merry
Christmas like ad nauseam one thing I'm
thinking a lot of our listeners and a
lot of David's listeners were tired of
how often do bom isaid Merry Christmas
but I digress the point is instead of
doing what a press secretary could do
should do and instead of like I mean I
would love for the opportunity to clown
someone who made this dumb of a mistake
but instead of taking that road he
decides to double down with this war on
Christmas and a tactic that is so
familiar from Donald Trump which is
feigning as though you are the victim
and then demanding someone apologizes
this to me is more about what the next
four years is going to look like right
instead of doing the sensible pragmatic
thing which was hey liberals you guys
are idiots you didn't even know that we
refer to Jesus as the new king you're so
dumb instead of doing that he decides to
go with you need to apologize for this
attack on Christ it's gonna be alone for
years man it's like he's the one who is
overly offended and feels like he's a
slight no flake he's a safe space right
i mean you need a safe space from
someone i mean he could have score so
many points on how uninformed liberals
are with regard to religion which they
want to be like I mean not in all
liberals like I'm a religious liberals I
knew what they were talking about but I
also saw how that statement could be
confusing but instead of doing what a
press secretary does he did what Donald
Trump does which is to double down all
stupid and try to force someone to
apologize this is gonna be an amazing uh
and by amazing I mean it hello this is a
radio show so I can say is gonna be a
crazy four years thanks for watching
this video before you watch the next one
remember we're raising money to expand
the david pakman show big league as well
as expand progressive activism go to
david pakman.com slash donate donations
of any size are much appreciated